vamos a hablar de colombia país que
tendrá su primer gobernante de izquierda
tras la victoria de gustavo petro en la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales el candidato del pacto
histórico obtuvo 11 millones 279 mil 917
votos la mayor cantidad jamás obtenida
por un candidato en unos comicios
presidenciales su opositor el populista
rodolfo hernández se obtuvo más de 10
millones 500 mil votos el reconoció su
derrota tras una jornada que batió
récords de participación superando el 58
por ciento de los sufragantes tras la
victoria miles de colombianos salieron a
las calles para celebrar en varias
ciudades del país esta victoria de
gustavo petro es que el triunfo de petró
supone también la histórica llegada a la
vicepresidencia de una mujer
afrodescendiente hablamos de francia
marc es una lideresa social del cauca
uno de los departamentos de colombia más
golpeados por la violencia en el país
petra masa promete abordar la profunda
desigualdad social y económica en
colombia
de la mitad de la población vivió algún
tipo de pobreza en su discurso además
prometió un mandato libre de odios de
sectarismo y puso la paz como objetivo
central de su gobierno aseguró que
buscará también un acuerdo nacional
donde todos los sectores políticos van a
ser bienvenidos vamos a analizar
entonces esta victoria de gustado pero
también un poco lo que fue su primer
discurso como presidente electo lo vamos
a hacer con claudia lugo ellas docente
de la facultad de finanzas gobierno y
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad externado en colombia
gracias claudia muy buena mañana del
lunes vamos a hablar entonces de la
llegada de este líder de izquierda
colombiano hecho e histórico que
significa entonces claudia para la
democracia colombiana que por fin exista
esta alternatividad está pues opción
diferente a la derecha que ha gobernado
colombia
buenos días raúl muchas gracias por la
invitación
y yo creo que este es el excelente y de
muchos significados lo primero que
quisiera destacar es eso que hablaste
precisamente de ser el presidente mayor
votar eso quiere decir que superamos un
límite de personas que salieron a votar
a la calle y eso es importante para la
democracia que significa tener
una alternativa diferente muchas cosas
en el término simbólico en el cambio en
el giro que da digamos un país que
siempre había elegido presidentes
típicamente derecha
y representa digamos una esperanza para
sobre todo la gente que votó por por
gustavo petro ahora vienen muchos retos
porque el reto más importante es que es
esta esta opción siempre ha sido
oposición y una cosa de ser oposición y
una cosa es hacer campaña y otra muy
diferente será empezar a gobernar y
traducir todas estas ideas en políticas
públicas concretas y que la gente pueda
ver y amasar ya vamos a hablar de eso
claudio pero pero queremos un poco
también esta participación histórica de
58 por ciento de los colombianos pues
habilitados para votar que salieron no a
entregar su voto en estas elecciones
históricas por donde lo vea uno porque
se movilizó tanto la ciudadanía digamos
que también en la primera vuelta pudimos
ver cuando se escogió la opción de
rodolfo hernández y gustavo petro un
hartazgo como de las clases políticas
tradiciones de la población será también
por eso que la gente se movilizó para
buscar el cambio que tanto quería bien
sea por raúl fernández o bien sea por
gustavo petro
yo creo que sí digamos que este es
importante que la gente cada vez a mí me
gusta destacar que creemos todavía en
las instituciones que este es un país
institucionalista y que cree en la
democracia que la gente cree en la
opción de hacer un cambio a través a
través de las urnas es importante que
que la gente salga y se movilice y cada
día y si evidentemente el hecho de que
dos opciones que eran radicalmente
distintas vamos al panorama que siempre
había manejado el país que estuvieran
como en la última opción si hace
definitivamente que la gente se movilice
para salir soltar en razón de de mi
interés personal porque una opción
política sea la que gobierne o mi
política sea la que no gobierne
vamos ahora a analizar un poco entonces
lo que dijo gustavo pero también en su
discurso del primer discurso como
presidente electo inclusión diálogo
economía habló de desarrollar el
capitalismo aunque dijo que no le
gustaba mucho para ver que era necesario
para el crecimiento económico del país y
algo incluyente en las regiones no
persecución política la paz cómo hacer
para que realmente todo lo que dijo el
presidente electo se materialice en un
país tan difícil y con tantos problemas
como es colombia más una desigualdad
enorme
bueno esto es un poco de futurología
pero pero digamos que yo creo que el
primer paso clave estarán en
nombramiento justamente de quienes lo
van a acompañar en estos temas que son
claves primero que hablas después de la
economía definitivamente encontrar el
ministro de economía va a ser un punto
clave porque como lo dice es una
transición de economía trae
extractivista a una economía más verde y
llamarlo así es un reto importante el
petró anunció mucho en su campaña temas
que tienen que ver con
pensiones por reforma tributaria todos
estos temas requieren un jalonamiento
importante y creo que el nombramiento de
la persona que va a acompañar digamos
esta etapa va a ser importante
los temas el retomar digamos un acuerdo
de paz mejorarlo o acogerse de mejor
forma es un reto también rodante
y aunque es un poco de futuro los días
pero fue un modo como como lo va a
transcribir lo primero es que forma el
gobierno va a ser interesante muy
interesante e interesante ver quién va a
acompañarlo en la transición a entregar
vamos de poder y saber un poco quién son
las personas que en la vida real van a
producir todas estas ideas y muy
rápidamente qué pena te interrumpa
porque ya se nos acabó nuestro espacio
para seguir conversando pero por
supuesto no hay que dejar un lado a rudy
fernández y estas 10 millones de
personas que votaron por él más de 10
millones de personas
como como como analizar en estos 30
segundos que tenemos este fenómeno y que
si realmente lo que hizo una campaña
digamos llegó para quedarse para cambiar
el método de campaña política de un
candidato en unas futuras elecciones
presidenciales en colombia por ejemplo
américa latina
la verdad es que rodolfo es un outsider
de la mano y habría que ver ahora que
despidió a cogeremos esta esta curul que
se le da como senador si realmente va a
capitalizar digamos esos 10 millones de
votos y si eso se va a convertir en
digamos en un nuevo exponente público la
primera contienda o el primer lugar
donde se va a ver eso valor las
elecciones regionales del próximo año
pero digamos que la tiene yo creo que un
poco duro en el sentido que
definitivamente él es una usar de un
outsider de la política y habrán muchos
y sobre toda la oposición que tratará de
acoger digamos votos que estén conformes
con el gobierno elegido